that was 12 a couple years ago and don't
remember him anymore
Edward Conlon joined the New York Police
Department in 1995 after years spent as
a part-time freelance writer he
chronicled his experiences in a weekly
anonymous New Yorker column blueblood is
his new memoir this program is an hour
good evening everyone I'd like to thank
you for coming to this evenings event
tonight I have the pleasure of welcoming
Edward Conlon in his book blueblood
Conlon describes his life in the New
York City Police Department
though he comes from a PAMP family of
policemen Conlon is also a hardier to
Harvard Graduate throughout his unusual
viewpoint Conlon writes in a gripping
style about what it means to protect to
serve and to defend the people of his
city in one of New York's finest
please welcome Edward Conlon thanks for
coming this is a book about being a cop
in New York and it's also got a lot of
family history in it my father was
briefly a cop and an FBI agent for a
long time in New York City his brother
was a cop in the Bronx for over 30 years
and my great-grandfather was on the job
starting in 1906 and going through 1940
and so it's almost a century in the
business and my my great-grandfather was
not the most honest policeman there
there ever was I'm given understand
he only retired from the job he ran a
horse room in Jersey and the transition
probably was pretty smooth
and you know he's a bad guy in the story
really not so much because he was
crooked because you know in the roaring
20s and the JSA's gambling and and
drinking and the corruption and went
with it birds more or less by popular
acclaim but he was more of a bad guy
because he walked out of my
great-grandmother
and so well he was going around as
Cadillacs and pinkie rings she was home
scrubbing floors so we didn't really
know much about him then we didn't get
the family stories that might have
softened things or made him more you
don't understandable or likable so this
is a section of our first meeting
whenever I find myself in an
out-of-the-way part of the city I like
to walk around a bit to stop by with
relatives or friends who won't haven't
seen in a while if I think about it I'll
know somebody just about anywhere in
town one day I gave my partner a lift to
Kennedy Airport which put me in the far
reaches of Queens on a balmy spring
afternoon so I decided to pay a visit to
my great-grandfather it would be a first
meeting at the st. John's Cemetery in
Middle Village I'm injured amid groves
of marble angels on high pedestals
moneyed and majestic and sentimental and
I could almost feel the cool of the moon
colored stone
I passed a bunker like mausoleum that
bore the name prophecy which with some
injustice but better lock escape
becoming a brand name of a mafia branch
now known as Colombo the brand names are
there too Columbo Gambino and Genovese
II and other bosses like carmine Galante
who helped to organize the French
Connection Charles Lucky Luciano who
became the next and last true boss of
bosses and John Gotti would be buried
there too in time so patty the cop
finally got his table at Rao's I thought
were spot at the bar an eternal
underworld Copacabana I would have
gotten along with him I think despite
myself New York has always been full of
heroes who are hard to like and villains
who are hard to hate my mother and her
sisters never spoke to him in any real
sense but Pat Brown did speak with his
daughter-in-law Marie by telephone a few
times and she recalls them with some
affection then again Marie had a knack
for
along with some very difficult men my
great-aunt Marie Doherty Brown Marcus
was a jazz pianist from Boston while she
was still in her teens her mother
brought it down to New York for her
first job at Kane's Chop House and told
her employer my daughter is a good
Catholic girl mister and if she has any
problems here you love me to answer to
yes mrs. Doherty of course mrs. Doherty
she'll be fine here was the response
from Dutch Schultz perhaps the most
murderous gangster of his day Schultz
himself was gunned down not long
afterwards by his underworld colleagues
after announcing his attention to kill
special prosecutor Thomas E Dewey
Schultz was a fairly doer character as
Murray remembers him though she was
thrilled when he included her and his
visits to the Cotton Club in Harlem
where she watched her idols Fats Waller
he'd given her piano lessons when she
was young cab calloway and other jazz
legends play from there she went to work
for Frank Costello at his Venetian
Palace where on one early occasion there
was an apparent misunderstanding between
them as to the nature of the
entertainment she was to Bride he sent
her to play at a private party of
mobsters at a hotel room and she was
utterly stunned to see the singers
remove their gowns before the first
verse when it appeared that one of the
hoods expected her to fall off soon she
fled the room and went back to the club
where she hunted down Costello and gave
him an earful much as her mother had
done Schultz and he apologized profusely
saying he had no idea was that kind of
party once Costello was straightened out
she told me she had no more problems she
met Lucky Luciano there and thought
Bugsy Siegel a very nice man who called
her the coca-cola kid because that was
all she drank her public was thick with
Public Enemies Murray married Jack Brown
and for a time they had an act together
in the clubs and hotels of Manhattan and
Brooklyn she played the piano and Jack
sang and when I asked what their song
was she laughed and said melancholy baby
as if it held some clue as to why their
marriage was not to last few people now
recognize that song as except as a
punchline but it seems to have in the
national anthem for the underworld and
it's tender moments
when asked what Dutch Schultz favorite
song was she told me melancholy baby
asked if she ever met my olanski she
said yes I'd see him on the beach in
Miami he was a very nice man too always
wanted to hear melancholy baby lost in
the cemetery I grew melancholy as well
the groundskeeper gave me directions to
the office and then gave me a look of
pity when he saw me circle past again a
few minutes later when I found the
office I waited for a woman behind the
counter to stop taking calls well the
phone seemed to ring every 10 seconds
she seemed like a new were nearly
retired teacher not quite in control of
an unruly class no I'm sorry but no
quotes no hyphens no nicknames she said
as if handing back a homework assignment
I think so I'm pretty sure but let me
check she said putting the caller on
hold to check another aspect to post
more than etiquette the father's
Catholic and he's in the grave the
mother isn't either but she's ready to
go can they go in the grave together the
answer was yes as she thought I thought
it was an easy question even a nostalgic
one walking back to a more defined age
with sharper edges when she had time for
me I told her the I told her I was
looking for Patrick Brown and that he
had lived in Brooklyn and died in
January 1946
I didn't say why I was there and she
didn't ask though there was a moment
when we both seemed to expect an
explanation I did feel a little guilty
as I was there to work the weather to
dig up Pat Brown a barium again I wasn't
yet sure she gave me a map that looked
like a placemat and traced the route
from the office to the grave filling out
the coordinates for section range and
plot 8g 22 in this case I found him
easily enough at the green edge of the
cemetery beneath the sycamore tree
beyond the fence was Woodhaven Boulevard
in a generic generic commercial strip
gas station Motel car wash auto body
he had a modest gray granite stone
polished and clean with a cross flanked
by two camellias on the lower left side
was his name and dates and on the lower
right was space for another mom had told
me that his second wife Margaret was
buried with him and the absence the
pointed absence said either that she was
buried elsewhere again
two wishes as my mother recalled them or
that no one had attended to the
inscription I sat down by the grave and
intended to say a prayer but instead
found myself daydreaming about things
was I the first to visit him in 20 years
13 what would he think I felt like I was
there to serve a subpoena and after a
while I went back to my car but I found
that I'd lost my keys they must have
fallen out of my pocket as I sat by the
grave as I walked out a woman carrying
two bouquets of flowers asked me do you
work here
where can I find some water I said I
didn't work there and I didn't know but
I needed for the flowers she said as if
I might have been holding out on it back
at the grave I found my keys and
remembered to say a prayer a Hail Mary
on our father before I took the day
dream again if you could call it that
because the day itself was like a dream
pointless and pretentious at once I got
lost while looking for my
great-grandfather's grave and found his
wife missing and then I forgot to say
prayers and my keys were missing and
then a woman asked me for water fur
flowers because she thought I worked in
the graveyard
I wondered if another piece would make
the whole thing clear and then as I
reached the path again I met another
item that carries a certain charge of
symbolism in my culture a dead rat it
was not just dead but flattened and
skeletonized softly gray and almost
transparent like a pencil sketch of
itself it was if a certain ancestor had
slipped me a subtle and coded message
and wouldna and when I did not rise to
the challenge that telegram would have
to be sent we can do this the hard way
or the easy way back at the office the
woman was surprised to see me again I
explained that my step great-grandmother
was missing and asked if it was simply a
neglected inscription or whether the she
was with a party named Sullivan whom I
believed to have died in the mid-50s at
a Catholic cemetery there is never any
shortage of Sullivan's and there was I
won't say digging some work to do to
Hispanic woman came in with their
placemat maps about to ask for
directions and to spare the woman from
distraction I took it upon myself to
explain how to find the section they
were looking for and how to read the
codes on the stones you should get a job
here one of them said and the woman who
was working there looked up from her
list of Sullivan's to say it's yours for
the asking
I was glad that the woman with the
flowers wasn't around after a while the
deed to the brown grave was found and it
showed that Margaret was not there I
called my mother today I asked her the
date of death she died in the 80s it
turned out at the age of 85 and we were
eventually able to ascertain that she
was in fact buried with her second
husband John Sullivan as well as his
first wife
I found them some 200 yards from Pat
Brown and saw the three names wife
husband wife on a stone almost exactly
like Browns with a cross and camellias
but twice the size with a well-tended
bed of begonias in front i sat down
there too
and began to feel indignant as if I'd
found them out and I also felt bad for
Pat Brown to have been left out
altogether
my mother was certain Margaret had
intended to be buried with him on the
back of the gravestone with several
different names probably also relatives
but the words had a sneaky look like the
answers to an exam written on the back
of the hand I thought this is how it
turned out so you poor Pat forever with
the knuckle heads stood up by your date
so that's Pat and this is a short bit
about the Bronx I've worked I've been a
cop for a little more than nine years
and I've worked in the South Bronx the
whole time and this is more about the
way it was for a long time than it is
right now but there were many bad
neighborhoods in New York but the South
Bronx was a byword for slum
there was no Renaissance and it's past
like Harlem there were any signs of
gentrification a renewal as there were
in parts of Brooklyn Fort Apache was the
nickname for the 401 just east of where
I worked
but the fort too was used as the station
house in the movie Fort Apache the Bronx
well the plot lines of interracial
romance and police corruption were
invented the landscape of urban
wasteland was not Fort Apache was later
known as Little House on the Prairie
because so much of the area had burnt
down my uncle Jerry had been a
firefighter in the South Bronx in the
1970s and he told me that there were
busier than London during the Blitz in
report from Engine Company 82 the
firefighter Dennis Smith
that they responded to as many false
alarms as fires and a man from his
company was thrown from the truck and
killed while responding to a false alarm
pulled by a nine-year-old boy a sign was
put up on the coal box telling of the
death and the danger of false alarms but
a false alarm was called in later the
same day from the same box so they took
the sign down I was born in the Bronx
but my family moved just north to
Yonkers when I was little I'd taken my
father's old apartment in the Bronx
seven years before the four rooms of
gloom over an aircraft where they where
he'd grown up it seemed like we owned
the neighborhood
Uncle Eddie a cop for 33 years never
left it and uncle Jerry's last firehouse
was three blocks away across the street
from uncle Nick's office Nick was a
doctor had married my father's sister
Teresa a nurse when I was a kid when we
drove through Kingsbridge my father
would point out where Joe Lewis had
lived and where Mike quill was but what
I remember most about the Bronx then was
the windows the abandoned buildings a
mile to the south the city had covered
them with decals of curtains and shades
with flower pots to suggest that happy
families dwelt within instead of junkies
and ghosts well the official motto of
the Bronx was ominous enough naicha dame
Alice do not give way to evil one writer
suggested that it should be get out
schmuck get out our official flower was
the corpse flower a massive jungle plant
so named because it's bloom smells like
rotting flesh
it was cultivated for the first time in
North America and the Bronx in 1937 and
and the borough president decided that
the 8-foot tall prick shaped flowers a
more fulfill a Steinem would prove an
app symbol for our future growth
however the corpse flower might go for
30 years between blooms which stink and
died within days I still can't figure
out what they were thinking on that same
theme of death in the Bronx it's just a
little patrol story
one of the ordinary things that every
every cop has to do when and kind of you
know in my view the best part of the job
because what you do all day as a cop is
you walk around you knock on the door
and people have to tell you a story in
this case the story was already done but
I might take your fear of what I mean
one old man lived alone and died
crumpled on the floor and the little
alley between the bed and the wall
wearing a dirty shirt and no pants his
room was small and cluttered and all his
clothes were in old suitcases were
stacked beside them as if he were
packing for a long trip there were two
televisions one old one brand-new a
manic kitten toured it up in mid the
piles of clothes and rubbish around the
body because he lived alone we had to
search for valuables in the presence of
a sergeant and vouchered them at the
precinct we found his discharge papers
false teeth and stacks of pornography
the other cops left and I stayed it was
my turn to sit on the DOA
waiting for the Emmy to have a look and
then the morgue crew to take him away a
man knocked at the door and said I took
care of him I'm his stepson he wanted me
to have the TV I told him to get some
proof and until then he should take the
kitten he left and I turned on the
television less than an hour later who
returned with a lady friend
both were roaring drunk and demanded in
unison we loved him we was his family
let's have that TV I closed the door on
him and sat back down there was a phone
call I waited and picked it up hoping
that whatever friend's a family he had
whoever cared for him would not learn of
his death by accident from a stranger is
mr. Jones at home no he isn't is this
mrs. Jones no but thanks for asking
when when will he be available and no
time soon when should I call back can I
ask who this is mr. Jones had recently
expressed an interest in our low-cost
insurance policies and he's not
interested and who may I ask is this
this is the police mr. Jones is dead
that's why I'm here well do you think
dead there may be some dead dead dead
he's stuck to the floor six up feet away
from me guy no sale
have you considered whether you have all
the coverage you need officer I hung up
and went back to watching television and
this is this is another story of the
kind of insane stuff ordinary stuff that
that cops go through and this you know
this this is in the South Bronx but
there's people like this everywhere and
maybe we know a few what can you say
most of the time in the end you say 90 X
90 Y a 90 Z these radio codes give
dispositions meaning unfounded
unnecessary a gun on arrival the terse
dispatch of them you can ex that central
can reduce an epic to a letter scraping
a clean of context all the drama and the
decisions my Uncle Eddie had been a cop
for over three decades when I first
looked at his memo books I was surprised
at how little they said given the zany
color of his stories the jumpy crabbed
notations of all normal and nothing to
report were barely less vivid than the
occasional mention of a parking ticket
issued three under arrest burglary but
in time they came to appreciate the
telegraphic brevity of the codes which
allowed me to finish stories I barely
knew how to start my partner angel and I
once went to a 10-10 a possible crime in
this case a dangerous animal condition
the complainant was a woman on the 19th
floor one of my buildings in a familiar
caller a stout opinionated lady in her
early 50s she claimed to be the frequent
victim of espionage on the part of her
cable company the housing authority and
several less terrestrial bodies against
which she protected herself by covering
the walls and ceilings of her entire
apartment with tinfoil I sometimes
wondered if it was a cop which suggested
it to buy a few weeks piece while she
busied herself with the defense's I know
it wasn't a fireman because the foil
which was tattooed all over with
pentagrams covered a thick layer of
crisp and dry news
mostly department store circulars for
men's underwear I need you to get rid of
my cat it attacked me it's crazy it
changed I can't have it here used to be
so wonderful it's a mystical cat you
know a Jewish cat I tried everything
petting it feeding it throwing boiling
water added nothing works nothing it was
5:00 in the afternoon and our options
were limited her son was with her a Lord
shambling man in his early 30s who kept
a weary and sheepish distance meeting my
eyes briefly when I looked to him been
shrugging and shifting aside it was too
late in the day to call the ASPCA for a
pickup I doubted the cat was dangerous
as much as I doubted the cat was Jewish
but the last thing I was going to do was
call emergency services when you call
out the SWAT team for a kitten other
cops tend to bring it up now and then
one guy couldn't talk on the radio for
months without hearing meows in the
background she rambled on I could have
called Auggie to take it out you know
walkies in the Mafia he'd kill anyone
for me but he can't do it now he can't
and the cats in my bedroom and I can't
go in I began to tell her that the best
thing to do was to confine the cat in
another room and leave it alone while I
would make an appointment with the ASPCA
to take it off her hands the next day
she'd have none of it and with one hand
on the hip and the other slicing the air
she let me know she dealt with my type
before you will take care of this now or
I'll call the housing authority I will
call your captain I will call Jim Jensen
at Channel 7 News I will call Eyewitness
News yes I'm calling now give me I
witnessed news as she marched to the
phone to punch random numbers I saddled
over the son and said listen why don't
you just shut in another room he looked
at me weakly and his mother hung up the
phone my son she hissed with dry
distaste is mentally ill
silly me silly all of us though I
decided our course by then I thought I'd
checked the cat just to make sure it was
in fact safe enough to remain in the
apartment overnight when I opened the
door to the woman's bedroom I saw a
small white cat lying on the bed a brown
patch of fur on its head did look
something like a yarmulke but otherwise
neither its religious affiliation nor
its Menace was obvious when I took a
step toward it however the
transformation was profound the back
arch the eat is flattened the eyes
narrowed and seed then spat like a cobra
on crack this lady this lady didn't need
a cop she needed an exorcist I withdrew
and closed the door ok I said the cat
has to go from their mother and son
became my loyal aides the camp and the
campaign that followed a large piece of
plywood was set up in the hallway to
block access to the living room and all
doors were shut except for those two the
mother's room in a smaller spare room
beside it the first phase would be to
isolate and contain the cat in a secure
area and the second phase the second
phase would certainly commence when the
first phase was brought to a successful
conclusion
angel kept mother and son stationed
behind the barrier as I put on my gloves
picked up a broom and re-entered the
bedroom again the cat bared its teeth
and swiped with its paws quarreling up
on the bed to prepare for a leaf but as
I came closer it bolted for the radiator
and the merry chase began the cat - to
the top of the cabinet and then to the
radiator then under it then under the
bed paused to turn and fight meeting the
broom and tearing at us I tried to hurt
it out the door again and again it would
bolt and then turn and fight and hiss
and spit it slides witnesses amazing to
see as its hatred once more it fled
before charging me and I fell back
swinging the broom and dodged and sped
into the hall but before the cries of a
criminal of a claim could have ruff from
behind the barrier the mother and son
fell back to was the cat race to them
leaping up and over the plywood as they
dropped it and pursuing them into the
living room where the field of battle
was greatly enlarged
get back get back I got it I picked up
the barrier again and sent them behind
it and once more engaged the cat its
rage speed claws and teeth against my
broom my paramilitary training and a
chorus of me I was on the radio echoing
in my head here it had the couch chairs
cabinets and shells an entire kitchen
for its guerrilla maneuvers and it made
use of all of them in his rounds of
flight and fight as I fought on without
success my supporters were galvanized
and the woman cheered me on and
brainstormed I know fire will burn him
out all animals are afraid of fire don't
you dare angel stop her I shouted but as
I swept the cat from beneath the drapes
he darted for the kitchen and after
reconnoitering above the refrigerator he
dove to the floor and under the stove I
paused to think and breathe as far as I
saw it we were still in phase one still
out on that 10/10 unit came the call
over the radio still out central clearly
there was need for further revision of
our strategy the barriers were changed
again so that they led to the open door
of the apartment once out I figured all
of us cat crazies angel and myself would
return to our better natures and reserve
resumed our lives on some sort of normal
footing also I didn't care anymore so I
returned to the kitchen and lifted up
the stove with a cat writhing beneath
had become coated with the grease of a
decade of break breakfast bacon and
Easter hams the broom seemed to hold no
more terrorists for the cat and I
wielded it less adeptly as I also had to
hold up the stove I had to escalate and
I gave a few blasts of mace the old kind
which was a kind of a weak cousin the
tear gas and though it had no apparent
effect on the cat it droves me choking
outside into the hall
as I guess for breath I saw if my
reddened eyes the woman leap across the
living room with a great cooking pot
stuffed with blazing newspapers the
flames reflecting off the foil walls all
animals are afraid of fires she shrieked
and I bellowed no and raced back inside
angel ran in to take her outside and
though I stamped the pot out before the
fire engulfed the apartment I was now
doubly choked by the acrid bite of tear
gas and the unfurling plumes of smoke
which set off the fire alarms throughout
the floor neighbors began to step out of
their apartments to investigate
I sent them back inside it's alright
folks the police are here everything's
in hand nothing to worry about I was
humbled and a little worried if help
arrived I would have much to explain but
the woman was delighted she called the
police twice a week and usually got a
couple of guys who walked away a minute
later muttering about straitjackets here
a hero had arisen who brought down
forces of destruction that might well be
commensurate with her perception of the
threat I'd turned the place into Beirut
and she couldn't be more grateful
I opened the windows until the air
cleared and I almost toppled the stove
to sweep the cat off from its refuge
ignoring the open door it bolted over
the barrier and fled back into the
bedroom they [ __ ] between bed and
radiator again as if to show the
learning curve for both cat and cop
remained flat before a tuk war for the
window and slipped outside to the ledge
and then they had a revelation a vicious
cat could not be put up for adoption
no matter the provocation a cat would
have no day in court my nemesis had no
future beyond being drugged bagged and
caged before being put down I moved
forward without thought but as if guided
by some mysterious force as I put my
hands on the window the cat scrambled to
turn and come at me but it lost its
footing and dropped from sight the woman
called the precinct four weeks
afterwards demanding to talk to the
captain to tell him what great work I
had done
but when the desk officer asked me what
had happened I just shrugged and
repeated but I told the dispatcher when
she asked about the job still out on
that 10/10 unit make that a 90 z central
gun on arrival
I didn't kill the cat is that clear the
suicide suicide that's it I could do it
again from the top well maybe there's a
question or two for this you know it's a
great job and it's nice I mean I did
some writing before but it's nice I mean
when I was writing before it was always
a pain in the ass to have to confront
the page you know the typewriter can you
had all day to do it and all day to
avoid it well when you work you know in
50 60 hours a week you know it's a
privilege to have that time and you take
much better advantage of it it's hard to
figure I mean in one sense you know what
I want to say uh a sequel right away but
this took five and a half years to write
so nothing's happening tomorrow
name now instead of a pseudonym well
it's the cat was out of the bag you know
when I got the you know book deal but I
wrote under another name I wrote a
couple of pieces about being a cop for
The New Yorker and I only had two or
three years on at the time and so you
know I had a couple of reasons both
because I didn't want people who I was
working with to be self-conscious I mean
cops are scrutinized a lot and nobody
likes to feel like they're being watched
at work and also since I was new I
didn't want to make it seem that I was
just doing this you know first story or
as a kind of stunt that I was sort of in
it for the long haul how did you end up
start or start writing I always wanted
to write and you know I was working as a
freelancer for a couple of years and the
stories I was I was writing a lot more
with crime in the city and I got to meet
more and more cops and you know when the
job wasn't lousy they loved it the way
that few people seem to so I figured you
know I was making handfull living
sometimes as a freelance writer I needed
a real job and I might as well do
something that that I might like which I
did and so it was not to write about it
who really it was to be able to write
what I wanted you know on my own time
and not have to depend on you know the
freelance freelance stuff
how does Harvard work into this story um
not too well I learned how to type there
in math at that was a useful skill as a
there's a lot of a lot of paperwork
involved in the police work and I think
cops should be paid by the word did you
have humorous things to say to your
fellow cops and fear supervisors I got a
whole book fold I don't know how do you
mean about without all of it about
something else or back why don't going
on at the moment
oh yeah that's everybody's when you can
you laugh and sometimes you laugh when
you're not supposed to but that's that's
definitely one of the benefits of the
job you know you you might meet an old
friend over a dead body and then you say
hey how you doing what's going on right
alright him yeah let's get to work
that's constantly
I know it's a big topic but can you
touch on I guess your experience with
911 and that kind of thing yeah I mean
that it's nobody nobody ever forget that
but at the same time I think a lot of
people almost have and not in a bad way
people walk by Ground Zero every day and
Wolfen they don't look up and that's
healthy in a way and it's also in a
heartbreaking because of it's not so
long ago but I'd been going to the World
Trade Center since it opened
I had uncles who had a restaurant and a
coffee shop and a bar at the ground
level the underground level D by the
path train so I'd been I'd been going
this it's where my family went out to
eat and when we went out to eat because
it was free and you know it was it was
familiar to me and I didn't I spent a
little bit of time at Ground Zero but
mostly like other detectives I spent a
lot of time in Fresh Kills which was the
name of the dump in Staten Island where
they trucked all the debris from Ground
Zero to be sorted through and there was
a hundred million tons of it it was a
very strange place because it's this
sort of big man-made mountain of trash
this big plateau but it overlooks New
York Harbor and so you wouldn't get
there and you would look out at the
harbor and you'd see the Statue of
Liberty Union you'd see what used to be
the twin tower is still burning still
you know with all this kind of willful
black smoke coming on and we were but
don't want to dusk so there are these
brilliant Sun rises and the smoke and
the Statue of Liberty was just an unreal
place to work and we worked through the
winds it was a crime scene technically
and detectives are in charge of crime
scenes so we had it alone for the first
couple of months and they brought and
you know lots of other people but we we
raked through all this stuff looking for
pieces of people basically
you think there have you seen on the job
since then that there's I mean they're
sort of was this redefinition of heroism
and this kind of bring renewed respect
for those different professions do you
did you see that in a day to day basis
in your job yeah for a while if that's
faded a little bit but I you know I
never thought it was that terrible in
New York I mean even in the worst you
know in crises in Giuliani and diallo
and Louima I never thought it was as bad
as people made it out to be I mean I you
know I started working a beat in the
South Bronx in a really bad area it was
claimed on village just you know group
of big tall classic you know brick
ghetto
housing projects and the thing that
really surprised me was how much people
really did like cops I mean a nice
neighborhood you notice a comp like you
notice a mailbox which is you know if
you need one maybe it's be glad to see
it but otherwise it's just part of the
background but you know in bad
neighborhoods people were really happy
to see it for the most part it meant you
were they were gonna get to work or get
home from work without being aggravated
no I mean even when I started which is
not you know the hell of a long time ago
it was you know this Fort Apache well
these burnt out buildings and vacant
lots and there's all this new
construction little little houses I mean
parts of it looked like Levittown where
we're you know the the kind of famous
part of where Jimmy Carter went and
we're president since then I've gone
it's it's this little suburban area I
mean it's it's not great it's still the
South Bronx I mean don't kid yourself
but it's a they I mean I've heard of
movie companies you know trying to shoot
you know get on movies in the South
Bronx but they can't find any more
abandoned buildings you know so stay a
tough luck
with your schedule what is your best
time to write and how long do you do it
at a sitting at best I think I usually
can do just three you know maybe three
hours a day so and I and I fortunately
have a terrible schedule at work
two nights two days and two off so I go
from four to one and then four to one
and finish it one and come back at 8:00
in the morning and to wait the fourth
but so I can work just about any anytime
where I'm not working a date or but you
know the New York City Police Department
is terribly paid but we get more time
off than Frenchmen make a lot of a lot
of time off which is a good thing from
the job and write down some of them oh
yeah you spy should have you know
something so you won't forget so when
you get a little bit more you know time
you can fill it out and deadlines are
always good help you organize and get it
done fresh air I enjoyed it and I was
wondering that in Europe I have any uh
any of your publicity events and
anything that's stuck in your mind
they haven't stuck in my mind you know
it's it's it's the other day I sat in a
box for six and a half hours giving the
same ten-minute interview right I
haven't been the same since
and how much corruption we were you
forced to face spa you know it's a cop
politics tons corruption
you know thankfully very little avenged
I've I've made I think three hundred
arrests myself that I've been present
for several thousand and I've gotten one
offer of a bribe which is hopefully a
you know a good indicator what the
market is no politics constant though
well inside you know regular politics
city politics and you know the internal
politics of the job I mean it's it's the
police department is just sort of a
make-believe world you know the order
and regulation because you that tries to
address the craziness that we that we
deal with I mean there's a 600-page
rulebook dealing with everything from
how to deal with a dead body to what
time of year you're allowed to wear
short sleeve shirts and on top of that
they say it's flexible so it's as if you
can memorize it and then throw it away
because you know you can't count on it I
mean another thing that always you know
the strikes B's ridiculous is we're not
allowed to have HBO or the precincts
because we might see a naked woman
whereas then we go out and we'll deal
with rapes and homicides instead of you
know but you know we can't be shocked
inside you know so I never figured
I'm back for the politics there been a
difference between the Giuliani
administration and Bloomberg
administration as far as how you're
treated perceived or way you can do it
well it's been better I mean you know we
had 9/11 in the mean time and in
Bloomberg is is less confrontational to
say the least and then Giuliani but I
always thought that's you know nobody
thinks that they're fairly covered by
the media you know it's just it just
doesn't happen but one of the weird
things especially about the Giuliani era
was that people saw cops as mini
Giuliani's that they were this you know
version of them that they meant you know
not just enforcing policies but kind of
aspects of his personality so you know
we were mean then but we're nice and now
because you know it things are a lot
more the same than different but you
know that's that's the the way things
were characterized
I'm going on about politics the up how
complicated would it be I mean dealing
with with your fellow officers who you
would theoretical at least I depend upon
for your life
how would that complicate things in
terms of politics if there would be a
problem well I mean I'm I with politics
being different with the book or yeah I
mean look another officer India and and
and you would they have to what you use
this person to back you up on the
straighter said well I've you know I've
worked with when when the book news came
out I'd been working in the same place
for several years and people know me as
a person and as a cop so that didn't I
mean it was just an interesting thing
that they had to fit around the fact
they knew and the same thing now I've
been I've been in a robbery squad in the
Yankee Stadium area for you know coming
on three years so they knew what coming
in and now but what the book is is is
mostly you know stories like I told the
kind of ordinary day-to-day stuff that a
cop goes through you know and so the
guys I work with are you know happy it's
told and happy to see the names in the
book though
right do you find very many cops who
read yeah they say there's a chunk of
them
I mean it's there's a you know obsessive
readers and buffs and you know war kinds
of types there's a good amount of you
know hard reading cops I mean but they
with the NYPD is this 37,000 cops
there's you know examples of every
stereotype and the opposite you know
this is an agency that is almost four
times the size of the FBI it's almost
the size of the United Nations it's a
huge huge there's more there's more
police officers in the NYPD then there
are people in Beverly Hills you know so
there's there's lots of everything you
think the TV shows that we see but a
daily basis just about actually depict
New York cops and appropriate manners
and it would be beautiful to go from a
crime scene to a conviction in an hour
you know a very nice thing I mean lots
of it lots of things a lot of TV shows
get a little bit right you know this
NYPD Blue
you know captures some language and the
feeling in a squad room and the way you
know cops think about cases a bored with
this world and really excited about that
one and the nice TV more than movies I
think for the most part get and get the
flow of it better just because it goes
on week by week and certain things
develop and it and feels more lifelike
not a lot of really good cop movies and
county monaghan French Connection is
great and recently NOC is also good
what inspired you to write like become
white I don't know I always I mean this
book mostly just to remember it I mean
every cop half the cops you talk to say
I ought to write a book one day I would
really really like we're even worse you
were to write my book next time but very
few try and see you succeed but
everybody goes through all this you know
crazy hilarious stuff and difficult
stuff obviously as well and mostly they
just talk about it with other cops but I
was afraid of forgetting it and I
forgotten tons already I'm sure but this
made me remember and keep it down
of you as a writer about the job
balances need also as a cop to preserve
all the science where's your boundary
between the two pulling you apart serve
um that was less hard than I thought it
might be I mean just to give you the
difference between this book and
something like NYPD Blue is you know
half the show is about you know the
murders of the week the cases the other
half is about office politics there's no
other half really in my book I mean
there is in the middle when when it sort
of forced itself into it but mostly you
know my guys who I work with know that
you know a great collar they make it
name they made you know might be in the
book but you know they're ugly divorce
is not it's just as well my ugly divorce
I never had one you know but there's
things that I'm interested in talking
about and things that I'm not so that's
that's a pretty pretty clear line and
generally I mean especially as a
detective now the similarities between
being a writer or a journalist or a
reporter whatever you want to think it
and being a detective are very very
strong you got to find out what happened
you got to prove what happened and you
got to make people believe you so it's
it works together more often than not
the only real competition is time did
you go into Harvard and how you did did
you go to Harvard knowing your
to be a police officer with her family
no I mean I grew up on cop stories but I
mean my father my father wouldn't want
me to be a cop I mean nobody wants the
kids to grow up hood and Patrol housing
projects in the South Bronx nobody does
you know people live didn't want the
kids to come back there they want to
move and in fact when a friend of mine
became a cop my father wouldn't nuts I
mean he was really was yelling at me all
the time I mean just because you know
his mother was an immigrant and he you
know he had a law degree and he an MBA
to where I only found out about that
where I found the diploma in the attic
and you know when he was a guy who
carried a gun for the government and
only left when he had to at the age of
55 and so he you know he had mixed
feelings about it because he had a you
know he's 55 year old guy with five kids
the youngest is five and you got to
start over again
I know maybe you know I should have
tried something a little different
little sooner and also the police
department was different when when he
made when he was deciding what to do
after the war I mean he was told come on
the job you'll get rich I'll go to the
bureau so he had a little bit out of
date a darker view of the job as far as
I was concerned but you know going on
the job well you might as well I mean I
don't go back to Ireland and you know
dig potatoes with a stick it's you know
it's not the way the generations are
supposed to progress so do you find
yourself really downplaying your
education at Harvard with coworkers yeah
I don't bring it up I mean it's you say
I hope we beat the Yale this year well
you know who cares I mean yeah I mean
it's it's it's a curiosity but it's not
really important to me when you think of
a New York police officer you think of
drama at least I think the average
person does you have a very comedic flow
is that how you work day to day you got
to be able to talk to people you know
that's that's that's what it is
I mean you and there's nine-tenths of
what it is I mean I've seen
you know I've been in a pizza parlor
where some loud drunk is mouthing off
and Carson and being a pain and do I get
involved
I mean he's not he's just being a pain
he's not being awful and this
eight-year-old kid steps up and says
stop Carson his lady's here he shut up
it worked you know and he took a much
tougher tone than I would have I mean
it's like would you please come on relax
but you know and and mostly you you got
to talk to people you got to calm them
down and you know like I got to get
confessions or I got to get statements
and you know it's not so much good cop
bad cop anymore it's good cop good cop
you got to be friends you got to be be
able to connect with somebody even if
you're looking to put them in jail for a
long time you got a you know connect
person to person you again going back to
family if if a relative of yours
mentioned that he was thinking about
that he's desperate with thing while
going becoming a cop Oh what would your
reaction be
I mean if somebody's desperate to do it
I just might be a little worried but
it's you really can't tell people to do
it and not do it they've and they're not
gonna know whether it's right for them
if they try but if they think they might
do it then I got thick skin and you know
can stand there in the corner there were
nothing for a long time because it's a
real big disappointment of the job for a
lot of people it's not that it's you
know will shoot out some car chases you
know your job for the day might be
seeing on a corner for 12 hours or
staying away from the corner I mean when
I was in the Academy might one of my
sergeant it was teaching there said you
know he almost quit when he was a rookie
because there was a riot or something
and so they had to and I will get all
the cops there and then all the bosses
you know didn't know what to do with
them so he was sent it was a freezing
winter night and they had him gored a
field an empty field I mean was somebody
gonna steal it and you know so he said
you know when it's when they waste your
time all the time you know and yeah and
it is pointless and
you have to have a certain ability to
deal with people wasting your time a lot
I hope that sells them
[Music]
if you're in a tough neighborhood for a
long period of time you know years does
it tend the brutalize person or does the
brutal person seek out that kind of
neighborhood you know when ever run you
know you read these books about you know
corruption you know mike McCleary wrote
you know buddy boys about a couple of
feet I really know I've been of serious
police scandals and when you in one of
these books he had one guy who
cooperated and talked about getting
burnt out and the slippery slope and all
that I never really bought it I mean I
thought he was a pretty he was looking
for a place to jump you know and I mean
it definitely does burn you out and wear
you out and in which case you try and
make a move you know just do something
different a different assignment stay
inside more given a car if you're
walking walk if you're in a car
it definitely burns you out but I think
the guys who really have done bad things
didn't take much pushing to get there if
you've been in a tight tense situation
for a length of time that you have a
kind of battlefield fatigue do they take
you and put you somewhere where you can
kind of recover well you know if they're
not very good at it but if somebody
usually I mean you you spend a lot of
time with the people you work with and
if you know that somebody and I was
getting the thousand-yard stare or is
just not dealing with things you know
you your boss or whatever usually try
and do something to have them cool out
whether to take time or you know
employee relations there's a couple of
different ways but obviously hasn't
worked or hasn't worked all the time
[Applause]
Oh my cousin you gotta have another
question how does your mother like you
when you when I went on the job but
she's this pretty happy now yes yes
couple more a couple more there we go
necessarily tough on marriage because
really have read that it is I mean
what's your for Yvonne now it is very
tough when I worked in narcotics we
would they change our tour every day you
wouldn't know till the end of the day
whether you're coming in at four o'clock
or one o'clock or whatever and I
couldn't imagine how guys with families
women with families manage that I you
know especially if the spouse had a job
too I'm the detective chart like I said
it's it's lousy but it's kind of
predictably lousy two nights two days to
Wharf and it's tough I mean there is
higher rates of divorce and alcoholism
and suicide in the put in in the police
department and many other professions
definitely tough very tough on families
I know I know but I also know a bunch of
cops who are married to all the cops you
know which is good and bad you know
because you'd get splitting up the shift
work you know you're in on that date or
I'm off on the midnight so it's
constantly running around especially
with little kids but I guess that is you
know misery loves company
yep Marcus laughs II which was my
grandmother's name who came over from
Ireland my father's mother and Mark came
after my college roommate it was killed
a motorcycle accident so the tribute to
him
it's the you know the my magazine pieces
were good discipline I mean it was you
know every couple of months you you
would just figure out a way of telling a
story about the stuff you've done I mean
the first piece I did was just a bunch
of patrol stories like the one you know
the DOA in the cat lady another piece
was on
police language you know just the weird
things that cops say and Street and talk
and how sometimes it's you know how
there's a regular street slang you know
a slab of quack I mean it used to be
crack came in vials and now comes in
these little little tiny baggies little
plastic baggies that I heat sealed and
he called slabs and now this is legal
language you know defendant did possess
one slab of crack you know as they get a
defendant did possess one made fat rock
of yoyo you know it's it's the street
language it becomes a legal language
sometimes and in the last the last piece
I did was when I was working on
Midnight's so and that had a lot of
history in it but you know I think
probably magazine pieces are a good way
to do a good way to go or at least for a
bit because they just you know they keep
your remembering and make you aware you
know of you know the stories that are
come in there and sometimes you won't
solve a case but you'll you know at
least get a story out of it I just had
one really annoying case where this guy
had a very expensive watch stolen by a
kid who worked for and the kid turned
out to have an identical twin and the
twins just kept on substituting for each
other coming in and interviewing and you
know would are you mad at you Joe Joe
Joe Joe I wound up locking up the whole
family
flute blood you know it's it's in the
blood
no one goes back and you know you know
what color it is it's you raised again
people who work in Internal Affairs how
are they regarded they're not loved oh I
mean it's sort of like the most perhaps
respect the need for it but they don't
like them you know we still call them
rats and tell the guys who volunteer for
it always looked at twice I mean even
though you don't understand it's
necessary you know you you don't like
root canal either you know you know you
don't like that and you don't like
getting watered it it's kind of one of
the ugly necessities of life I guess but
you're not grateful for the dentist or
anybody's when he's in there drilling
where do you see it clear in the forest
going I'm gonna stay a detective I like
that work I don't you know it in New
York City that from you take test to be
promoted sergeant lieutenant captain and
from there it's appointed inspector
chief and and so on but I don't want to
be an administrator I don't want to be a
manager I just you know I like my bad
guys and good guys and just running with
a case which is a lot of fun yeah yeah
yeah so I'm in a robbery squad now on
the regular precinct squad I'll probably
be there for a while then I'm down the
line homicide a cold case or something
that's a little bit more specialized you
get a lot of junk work even in you know
in a busy place I mean I mean detectives
investigate everybody knows that but a
lot of people don't really realize how
UNMISS the I mean if for example Jane if
I punched you and you call the cops and
I stayed here a patrol cop would lock me
up if that happened and I ran away that
would become a detective case right you
know
this is no great deep investigation
finding out where I am and my cousin
Eddie hit me again and you know and the
detective would go collect me other
times you know there's a body on the
street and we it's very hard to figure
out what happened and you know that's
that's and that's the great part of
detective work
I mean you it is mysterious sometimes
and sometimes we get it right I like it
a lot more I mean it's I mean drugs and
domestic violence or what makes crime
happen and if you got rid of them you
could send 2/3 of the cops in New York
City home or anywhere I'm sure and so
even though you know you're glad the
drug dealers are bad guys and they do
lots of other things you sort of only
working with bad people and you know you
you might be making a neighborhood
better or in some way or a block or a
building but it's it's sort of broad and
a little abstract but it's you know when
robbery I got a victim I got somebody
who got hurt and somebody's talking to
me and I'm making them feel better you
know whether I catch them or hopefully
I'll catch him but you know feeling
better just by talking to them and
showing you know that I'm working for ya
we used to just do robbery but now we're
doing all kinds of larceny and identity
thefts which your huge pain in the neck
you know something you know yeah it's
less serious but it's more common and
it's more difficult you know you because
you know somebody stole your social
security number and they're having you
know TVs delivered in Oakland California
they're not sending me out there to look
you know and it's it can be tough
sometimes but a robberies is is local
you know it's somebody from the
neighborhood it's a group of kids I know
they're local if it's this single guy
it's probably more serious and I'll have
somebody look at pictures from the whole
borough people guys who have a you know
girl she'd somebody who's done it before
and robberies is often more difficult
than homicides of shootings because
homicides and shootings in the majority
of cases there is some relationship
between the
and the victim whereas robberies between
strangers and that's you know that's
it's a more generally difficult
investigation so a lot of times they
stalk people in that just because you
really you know you cut your teeth there
Edward Conlon is author of blueblood
it's published by Riverhead books an
imprint of the penguin group visit
penguin com for more information
[Music]